happy December 1st reject nation that
means it's Star Wars month Christmas Day
hell yeah we're gonna watch the
mandalorian chapter 4 Bryce Dallas
Howard rented this one too ooh fantastic
actress that sincere I think do you
gotta give a couple of shoutouts first
one Eric over at nerd chronic thank you
for editing the reaction highlights for
us he's done work for Eamon snow a
Cookson movie trivia chipmunk down he
has podcaster of a podcaster found like
on podcast sites this is gonna be cut up
into reaction highlights our full-length
reaction stream along for the
mandalorian will be over at our patreon
page we do stream along for many shows
those include Cobra Kai season to Gotham
ages of shield and then there are shows
where we have the stream along option
but also have reaction highlights for
them at our patreon as well reaction
it's like how you'll see in this video
those shows our attack on 7 my hero
academia movie included Death Note Code
Geass Hunter hunter supernatural and
there are other shows we have stream
along as a reaction highlights including
for them as well but the Mandalorian go
tune in with us over there and because
the Mandalorian comes out once a week
want you guys make sure to hit that
subscribe button and click that
notification about so you'll be notified
when our next Mandalorian reaction is up
let's swing into this pray to God red
letter media covers that's beautiful
shot get all them colors this town is
ethnically diverse Oh Bryce Dallas
Howard brings so much Jurassic world
flare in here huh oh damn
oh he's like Lord of the Rings yeah oh
why then why the Troy or the Rings art
or across from the dog now there are a
lot of green or a lot of desert
I heard Pedro Pascal took home the baby
Yoda has a little prized possession
[Laughter]
what's your business here business oh
wow there's not much businesses liar I
will throw in a flagon of spot ja just
for good measure right back with that
this is code hello kill everyone in
there mando I was gonna be so many
cosplayers ISM Oh predator predator
vision treadle Orion I bet we're not the
only ones there several drawings
oh great fall oh come on mando oh hey I
see unique way to do that
ticking standoff Westar Stannah ha ha ha
following that's a great soup that's why
I came out she's so hot yeah that's what
I figured it's why we had that fight
scene that's been around she unless you
want to go another round one of us is
gonna have to move on and I was here
first
he just want some wood waiters we have
money how much it's everything we have
sir you have lodging yeah that's no
lodging the only planet to have it did I
hear that correctly Rock the baby oh oh
no they're gonna come surrogate parents
oh she's just blessed them real green
episode this is mm it's a carbon
efficient planet everyone's in green hmm
knock knock with Devlin mandolin is the
Mandarin with mandolins man again you
already I don't know your village was
raided though by dog people do you mind
if I ask you something how big is how
long has it been since you how long
close he has a predictor yesterday it
takes off sometimes someone else I'll
kill you
this is a I wasn't much older than they
are my parents were killed and the
Mandalorians took care of me these
people realized they got a handsome ass
Hispanic accurate celebrity boy-toy
Pedro Perez yeah not disappoint when
they face oh oh he's gonna eat Oh
with all those at least his mouth oh
he's like Wilson on home improvement
[Laughter]
whoa
we're not EST Imperial Walker curse
can't live here better but there are
only two of us no there's not there's at
least 20 here trade in train the village
oh let's get down to business cannot
fight that we show them how exactly I've
seen other action movies I know how this
goes
who knows how to shoot oh yeah awesome
and you also happen to be the hottest
one here hot single mom
awesome damn was it this music that you
probably can't hear on the reaction
because I love how this is like a
tradition this is like the very
traditional actions kind of story of
protecting the village guy the
townspeople you train them so yeah I'm
looking to go Terminator dark fate babe
yeah sorry guys
[Laughter]
[Music]
so the new iteration I love it they
actually made this is kind of scary
yeah take a page a drastic world gr nose
right in high heels it's a good thing we
trained you for one hour know
why are none of you people get it down
whoa
come on buddy ooh I love the painting
shots yeah I'll cover you
- the last night whatever you guys doing
okay oh sure why not
oh no this the speargun this is their
time Oh
oh it's bad it's bad anger st me
yeah let's do shooting in the eye
tit sit bone
a long time ago in a galaxy far far away
two people learn teamwork that's right
how to support each other and improvise
[Music]
become a vegetarian I'm leaving him here
what traveling with me that's no life
for a kid I did my job he's safe better
chance at a life you got to protect him
though he's little
he'll get over it he's 15
no you can't abandon Orion this is ha ha
that's good we want you to stay Oh
community's grateful you and your boy
can have a good life and your boy oh he
could be a child for a while is he
crying he's choked up a little oh it's
not gonna happen the guy's gonna show ya
Oh No oh snap
ya know
go get the kids no no no no oh hey hey
don't rope I'm working good that had Dan
that fake out that fake out never works
on me yeah
Sophie's yeah actually when he was there
sighs was his helmet still this size
does that to be Matt the show I know you
just killed although that was like you
proposed that he'll stay here and then
Angela will look after good bye bye like
this these people
well Bryce yeah did your father would
solo you are the best you are the bow
words correct is a star war
mandalorian goes full-on magnificent
seven accepts it's magnificent to ban
magnificent to or Seven Samurai
yeah it's funny because Star Wars has
always been you know like Oh moshing
classics and this kind of went full-on
away dommage you like this yeah this is
exactly the deploy right yes if he walks
battle of and Oh exactly
really liked this episode man I think
Bryce Dallas Howard is a damn good
director I was weirdly I was thinking
about Bryce toss hair I was a way out
Colorado this week think about her whole
week oh wait I just couldn't get my
stuff out of my lines you popped up in
something I was watching that's like
really like when Bryce Dallas Howard
plays antagonist type of characters or
like crazy kind of people you know when
she plays like normal good people from
not as John der performer Man 3 but when
she plays like weird kooky or something
or villainous I really like her anyway I
thought she did a really good job
directing this episode a little more of
a family-friendly fantasy vibe is weird
because you know you even though the
fact that you're you're a lodging is
something direct to Seven Samurai you
kind of have this like harrowing theme
and you got this pretty you know
despairing opening sequence where a
village is being raided for some reason
as the episode progressed it felt a
little bit more on the maybe it's
because of the vibes and the character
development they had with mando yeah
here where he's clearly tempted a he was
set on leaving the child calling them
now switcher to baby yeah he should name
the child by this point
Fred Fred Yoda Freddy Laurie and Laurie
attorney what wanted to leave the child
behind then you could see he's even
tempted with O'Mara possibly settling
down with her they kept doing all these
teases seems like there's this the fine
line this show will eventually cross
where when he does take off the helmet I
feel like maybe by the end of this
season or beginning of another season he
will have a completely different type of
adventure if he does fully I think
that's why even what would the
background of he is not you know
mandalorian born
mandalorian adopted yeah I think it kind
of transition into that storyline
eventually where he does take the mask
off I mean it's still raising some
questions about the mask well yeah the
lifestyle is in there wondering does
that mean he once he says you can take
it off in front of somebody he can't put
it back on when I was like is that a
like a theoretical thing like like you
know you've broken the rules and thus
you you shouldn't you can't or is it
like the helmet won't go back on like
will it destruct what is it program to
like know that and close off forever and
like a sign of your I think it snowed
like a religious statement it's like
Jackie Chan with the ponytails and
Shanghai noon is that it is interesting
that this episode does borrow so much or
or least dommage so much a magnificent
seven butts more specifically Seven
Samurai because the Mandalorian culture
has certain aspects that feel very akin
to samurai culture and those kinds of
rules we are well versed in samurai
culture Bushido yeah please in the vague
amounts I've picked up over you know
history lessons and stuff it does seem
like they have that kind of order so
maybe by the end of the season I don't
know but like if he were to take off the
mask for some reason and become like the
unmasked DeLorean maybe in the season
two he could be some sort of Ronin
situation yeah exactly
that's where I think it's headed
although I'm gonna nitpick here when he
took off the mask in this episode puts
in his face too like exposed or they
could just look I liked what the moment
was about but at the same time I was
like anybody could just look through
that right in the window in the light so
I thought they could have easily just
spotted him maybe he knew that though
maybe he was hopefully like secretly
hoping she was what if he's in a room
full of people and he has to eat it he
has to eat or he's like when somebody
just has to like their auto-ship and
it's like this is just not even
space-car yeah like lift up the bottom
how much face can he not show a little
wiggle room here can you get a
spider-man kiss like he likes like yeah
can we get look can we slip like a straw
over there
logistical thing about the heaven I have
very cute this is the first episode of I
think did address it that is like oh
yeah he just waits for a quiet moment I
guess takes Delmon off and eats at the
same time like does that ever get
inconvenient like is there ever a moment
where like you need to eat like it's a
mercenary to or at least is about to get
I'm sure you need to keep your physicals
on point there's about three minutes
breaking down the logistical rules of
the LP but I like that this is giving us
that to talk about in a way that isn't
frustrating that isn't like why can't
they get these rules but it's like makes
you it brings you in I thought would
that the car at dune yeah Gina Carano
snicker let's cut our jacket right now
Carano do it would her character I yeah
that's true I thought they were going to
start doing some jokes get a Marvel kind
of humor Disney humor or whatever at
this point when she's talking to him
about it like you could just take off
that mask you could settle down with
this village right here yeah I thought
you can start making fun of asking the
questions the audience rush your teeth
you know like what I do how do you do
this and this
I thought Gina Carano was really good in
this episode I don't think she exceeded
expectations in order I think she under
deliver she was exactly what I would
expect from Gina Carano to be a badass
Star Wars character yeah because her
character isn't written with the most
depth you don't really get to know her
that much you get a couple details that
at least endear you to her like yeah
part of my resistance fighter she's
badass I really don't mean for that to
come across insulting yeah I think a lot
of it does come down to right well so
you know I'm really seeing Gina Carano
do anything where you know it requires a
lot of emotional I liked her presence a
lot a night you left the episode hosting
that we would see her again in some
capacity she's got good charisma yeah
and I like the way they came straight
off each other yeah chemistry with that
shiny mask of his well and his body
language this was probably the most
dialogue he's got him yeah man mando
himself and the most emotional moments
he's got it and he has the mass he's
talking on Mara and she's like wouldn't
she like that he's like what's hunting
me
what this little green creature that's
gotta get on come from what if you
sneeze in the mask yeah what do you have
a bad sneeze dude someone gets in the
lens over there must be provisions he's
gotta have a loose mouth covered with
something and his nose exposed I don't
know don't make fun of Star Wars got a
head like franchise be sure you speak
exactly the right way of us know you did
get a little bit more of the emotional
side here I like these constantly being
confronted with like humanity
he's Gaza Lee being confronted with
emotion the Imperial Walker I thought
was Annie Walker's where they had this
standoff that room right if you have
Jurassic world
part 1 when Chris Pratt takes all the
Raptors into the woods a standing across
from the dominance rex it's gonna make
me wish the Bryce Dallas our could
direct the next Jurassic but the
Imperial Walker I thought with the red
eyes and having a little bit more of a a
monster thing about it I thought was
neat because when they go into the woods
it's got the giant footprint yeah like
they're building up this sort of ominous
vibe to this Imperial Walker Imperial
walkers like Hal has times at this point
and somehow just one of them in this
situation they managed to make really
scary yeah really scary and threatening
like a dinosaur
all the location environment is really
cool the swamps the woods now the greens
like Star Wars does - it's like either
really green over here yeah we're seeing
Rises guy walkers are gonna go to
something like let's go nicely yeah
please see that I feel like the new wave
of Star Wars Lee what have we not done
yet not we haven't a lot ice lately
juice more ice some snow once in a
waffle Empire did it no I didn't water
again no no Gungans weirdly this episode
is one of the longer ones I still think
it could have been longer I felt they
kind of moved a little too fast
especially in things like the training
in terms of like identity to the battle
and all that everything was just moving
along pretty quick like I got what they
were doing and cuz this was honestly
probably the most conventional I'd like
what they've been doing in terms of like
oh yeah familiar action hero stories and
putting them in this episodic serialized
format
which i think is neat but then here it
was all kind of predictable because it
was so by the tropes that and that's why
I thought the fake-out baby you'd be
honest about to be killer than Gina
Carano shoots the guy I was impressed by
that because that's another generic
action that we've seen and like this was
really by the numbers in like almost
every moment how things would go you can
kind of predict and so it did hamper
some of that tension yeah and so that so
I felt like well they could have made up
with that with a little bit more
breathing room other than just feeling
sorry for the village just a little more
character yeah like something O'Meara
knows how to use a gun which is cool but
I didn't really feel much of the reward
when they conquered at the end you know
I wasn't like yeah the villain a thank
God I really really gave it look I I
feel bad for them sure you know I don't
want to spend like episodes here but I
think they establish something at the
end they've been there I was about to
say that definitely is I think
symptomatic of kind of the time expanse
yeah this episode is yeah when he said
that or she said that I was like oh wow
this is two weeks later so he was so
obviously was gonna they're gonna train
them yeah and I you know I mean like
it's a few more minutes I could have
used a little moment of Gina Carano
being like you know like yeah are you
doing it to raise the stakes so even if
we knew they'd win just something to
raise this tension and stakes a little
bit yeah cuz I mean I really loved their
interplay and their teamwork in training
everybody and so I think yeah maybe
giving a little more breathing room to
every major component of that might have
been helpful because especially that is
like you're training people who you make
very clear are not prepared for this
yeah yeah and so it's it's not that it's
bad but yeah it is a little truncated
and thus it just yeah you're gonna use
like fifteen to twenty or - I think we
can hour-long episode yeah just just to
flesh out a little bit more of these
moments let them hit I don't think
predictability or or plot points that
we've seen done before are bad as long
as the emotional moments hit and I
thought there were some beats I just
didn't hit as strong as they could have
well I think that that last fake out is
is really nice because it's a little
sophisticated thing is that they already
have you thinking he's gonna shoot mando
and then he looks over to baby Yoda and
and even her sneaking up on him it's
like you don't have a good read on where
she is during that scene but that's
something that's very plausible within
her character exactly so yeah it's like
that
really was a crisp moment that is
conventional of because it has the exact
right amount of room to do its thing the
episode didn't necessarily get time for
that it's sort of like once you see
everybody train you check back in with
them to show that hey they use the
training and then we watched basically
as mando and and cardoon you know dude
the most crazy part
yeah is Laurie and I and I think they
did well to make it will the things step
in you know like we got to get it to
step in I thought that was a nice at
least injector for tension you fight
some of the time issues because I could
have easily been a super easy barely an
inconvenience moment yeah that's like
working yeah right yeah so thought this
was a really cool episode really enjoyed
my appreciation receptive this show just
keeps coming up every episode saying
yeah yeah one I thought the the ideas
they flirted with about like is he gonna
leave baby Yoda and then all that stuff
like those I thought hey well and and
made me wonder what the fate of
everything's gonna be coming all right
guys what what did you think of episode
four make sure to subscribe and click
that notification bell to get notified
on our next Mandalorian reaction is make
sure check us out our patreon page I
like to end this with a page for the day
shot to a man named Joshua Williams Josh
now Josh he pledged while I was out of
town normally when someone pledges what
I do is I send them a message asking
like hey what's up gate know it's like a
personalized or shadow
so John covered that basis for me it's
been a few days josh hasn't replied you
know why cuz I think he knows John is
the one who sent the message to him why
would I want to talk to John man I want
to talk to Greg Greg's the one who
usually leads the shoutouts I'm only
gonna give my personal information -
don't worry Josh I know how you think I
don't know how you feel I want to talk
to Jon either if he wasn't my best
friend that I've known for 20-something
years
it's pretty big I like that technicality
that's what keeps this guy it's like it
perpetuates itself no such a good Bogdan
had a lifetime's worth of bonding time
it's a little bi relate I wouldn't be
around this man today but Josh okay I
don't want your personal information
either Josh don't send me your life
story
reply to us as soon as you can buddy I
you're enjoying the patreon page thank
you for being you hope you had a good
Thanksgiving hope you gained some weight
hope now you're stressing about having
to lose some weight
yeah Gary for Christmas will get even
fatter or if you're Jewish but if you're
atheist don't celebrate anything what if
you're Jewish she'll just get fat Monica
Annika Hanukkah you will get fatter